the european central bank has been
conducting an experiment for nearly a
decade now they had negative interest
rates and that monetary policy the whole
idea was to constantly ease the
environment they wanted more and more
people to be able to borrow cheap
capital on top of that they wanted to
actually incentivize investment and all
sorts of monetary velocity in the
european economy now of course as we
were in good times that was a great
policy and they kept the party going but
now that all of a sudden asset prices
are crashing recession is looming on the
horizon pressure is coming on the
european central bank will they keep
their interest rate negative or will
they actually capitulate and change
strategy after almost a decade will the
federal reserve in the united states
they've gone ahead and started to
increase the interest rate they've done
so fairly aggressively but the ecb
christine lagarde the president they've
been holding out over the last couple of
months they said that we're gonna break
from the federal reserve we are not
going to actually do what they're gonna
do we're gonna stick to our plan well
ladies and gentlemen as these things
usually go christine lagarde and the ecb
they're changing their tune just this
morning they've gone ahead and they said
that they're actually gonna go and
they're gonna replicate what the federal
reserve's doing they're gonna increase
their interest rate they're gonna bring
it back to zero it's comical that that
aggressive move from negative interest
rates to zero so controversial but they
went further on and they said that
they're actually going to continue to
increase interest rates and they'll
probably bring them back positive again
in europe over the coming months this
means that the ecb and the federal
reserve in lockstep are going to
continue to increase interest rates as
interest rates goes up capital becomes
more expensive and asset prices
especially those in growth stocks tech
stocks or things that count on future
cash flow and revenue those asset prices
are likely to come down and so we are
watching central banks push us closer
and closer to recession they're making
money more expensive they're
manipulating the interest rates higher
and whether they had a plan to ease or
not over the last decade all of a sudden
is getting thrown out the window the ecb
finally has capitulated that negative
interest rate plan that loose monetary
policy it's all out the door they now
are raising interest rates and they say
that they're committed to making capital
cheaper and to getting inflation under
control we'll see how long this lasts
but over the long term i think they're
going to be right back to loose monetary
policy faster than they expect